so i'm very very excited for this
conversation uh season 41 of survivor is
shaping up to be something quite unique
before we get into all of that stuff rob
lauren i want to get first impressions
on the contestants on the castaways is
there anybody there that's sticking out
to you and for what reasons
rob
you know there's such a
wide variety of uh great contestants to
choose from this season uh one of my
favorites is uh jd uh that he's just
somebody who's just such a affable
personality and i think that he's gonna
be very underestimated this season
lauren what do you think
you know i'm gonna have to stick with
all my melanated queens i love chantelle
i love erica there's a lot of canadian
representation on there so yeah i'm
excited to see how it shakes out
honestly i don't have any
i don't i'm very wary and i know rob is
wary as well to say favorites right off
the bat we want to see them play you
know um i think rob and i have both
experienced being pre-judged before we
went out there so i want to see how
these players play
that's one of the big things i think as
a viewer you have to keep in mind you
might love someone's personality right
off the bat but you never know how the
game is going to go do you think it is a
mistake as for someone to like
really fall in love with the personality
of a castaway before they get a chance
to see which way the tides are going to
turn
well i think that you know if you fall
in love with somebody you know
you got to live uh that if you if you're
you know let your heart do what your
heart wants to do if you fell in love
with somebody in the first episode
that's that that's your person and you
can always pick a new person we won't
judge you if you pick somebody if they
do uh something that's not so great
later on or make a bad move look uh that
that's part of uh the journey on the
show
does anybody on there remind you of like
yourself before you went through it
hmm no these people are way more
polished uh than i was uh
we're lucky nobody reminds me of me it
was early goings for you rob though it
was early going yeah yeah it was earl it
was early on uh none of us knew what we
were doing
lauren et canada's had the pleasure of
speaking with uh fellow soul survivors
at clinton heart london holland bryce
johnson and you know you guys have been
holding survivor accountable to you know
making sure that there's diversity and
inclusion so do you see that in this
case i mean you just mentioned it and
then the people that are your favorites
you think this is going where you have
been intending for this few
i absolutely think so and it's so nice
to see and refreshing to have people
that look like me on on the show you
know um also i've talked to a lot of the
41 and 40 tours and i said this in
another interview with rob but they also
are doing 50 black indigenous people of
color behind the camera as well so when
i was out there there was like one maybe
two black cameramen i heard the doctor
has switched although we love dr joe
i've heard the therapist he switched as
well um so it's just nice to hear the
survivors actually sticking to what they
said and i think that this is just going
to make for a greater survivor community
yes and and hopefully reflect in the way
that um
the way the game itself sort of treats
the castaways and the way the castaways
are reflected on screen as well
absolutely i think you know jeff loves
to say survivors and microcosm of
society and i've heard a lot of people
saying things like oh this cast is
giving me weird vibes and i'm like let's
just wait and see how they play i'm very
wary of people putting out negative
things about this cast because it's
really important that we do highlight
the diversity on this season absolutely
absolutely now uh jeff probst in
promoting this new season has been
consistently touting this as like the
beginning of a new era for survivor
saying it's the most dangerous ever and
then making this big metaphor about how
survivor is a
monster so
i'm sure you guys have ideas about
what's going on or you might know what's
going on is there anything that you guys
know that uh fans can be excited about
rob
well one i'm
personally very scared uh that yeah you
know i i didn't i wasn't asking for the
monster but the game is going to be
shorter and i i think to compensate for
the game being shorter uh they're also
going to try to make the game much more
physically punishing so they're going to
really cram a
days of punishment into a 26 day package
for these players and they're not going
to be getting any sort of uh food
rations and they're going to do a lot of
other things to make the lives of the
survivors even worse and i don't know i
thought it was already pretty bad
yeah lauren knowing how tough it can be
out there how bad it already was
the idea that shortening this thing but
making it more intense does that give
you um more confidence in the castaways
or like what are your initial thoughts
on that absolutely you know before
everything dropped about the season
there were rumors is the season going to
be shortened because of cobit or
whatever and when it came out a lot of
survivor fans were up in arms like oh
that's not fair they don't deserve the
million i think jeff is trying to make
sure that we see that they deserve that
million dollars by not getting a daily
food staple by not having you know
bountiful rewards like we had um
survivor is hard if you spend one day
outside in the jungle my hat goes off to
you so i think these castaways are going
to be serving in in all kinds of ways
and i'm so excited to see
i think one of my favorite sort of
through lines
when i was looking at who this who the
castaways are was them all saying well
i'm going to win because i'm determined
i'm going to win because i never give up
and yes that is obviously a quality that
you need to have but is there something
that you know viewers and even long time
viewers
don't realize about what it's like to be
out there that you know everybody thinks
they know
from watching for so long rob
well i think that the underrated part of
the game is uh having a great social
game uh like lauren uh is a great
example of and i think that when you're
able to get along and play nice uh with
everybody at least like on the surface i
think that that's really gonna open up a
lot of things for you so that's where
that making the game so hard is going to
really complicate things so maybe we
don't know exactly how this is going to
go because if the game is even more
punishing you know uh we know that okay
well we know the people that are going
to be able to
have the best social game are the people
that are going to do the best but it's
going to maybe change the equation this
season
what do you guys
think about the idea that like the hype
around the season is so huge
and you know it's been a year since
winners at war aired right over a year
since winners of war air and the hype is
massive for this what does that say
about survivor's place
and its grip on pop culture
i think it just speaks volumes to why
it's the longest running reality
television show
ever and i i like the changes i think
that it's very smart of jeff to make
those changes i've got about 350 000
survivor nerds on tick tock that are
ready to go some people that just fell
in love with survivor during quarantine
so i think it's going to be so much fun
to watch and so cool to see
rob what do you
want to see like what are the elements
of a show of a season that make it like
a winning season what do you want to see
for this one
well i think it comes down to two things
it's really about the the cast and the
game play where we want to really have a
season with rich characters that uh all
sorts of people can identify with that
are very fun to watch you look forward
to wednesday so you could spend time
with these characters again and then i
think that we want to see people who are
all really going for it and not being uh
too afraid to make moves and that
everybody wants to win and that's
usually is going to give us a great
season
lauren what about you what do you want
to see unfold in this season like we're
already seeing
on screen the diversity that we've been
um wanting for a long time that you're
holding them accountable for and also
behind the screen uh behind the scenes
excuse me what do you want to see unfold
this season i want to see a female
winner like we haven't had that since
game changers right or what is it rob
sarah lost our last female winner and
you know i hate to just put it to that
i'm sure the nails are great as well
um and i do have a personal favorite
evie she was like
uh what's your biggest pet peeve and she
just said men period and that was it so
going in with that kind of energy i want
to see some strong dominant females i
think a lot of the times when you have
these duos you saw it on my season i was
a duo with a male and all of the credit
goes to that male i want to see some
female domination even if it's a power
duo of women um or a group of women a
women's alliance everybody's so afraid
of that um and i really want to see that
play out
awesome well it's i gotta say it's been
an absolute pleasure having you both
here to talk all about this it's gonna
be a super exciting season i'm also
looking forward to seeing over the
course of the season what you guys have
to say your analysis and all the rest so
again thanks for joining us
thank you thank you so much carlos
you